[Music]
him
stand that tv plugged in
[Music]
i was struggling to sleep nearly lost my
mind i thought they said my mama
ain't got much time and we just lost
jackie that caught me by surprise she
supported my grind back when i had the
[ __ ] consign but i'm
back with a bag and a bang again still
in the lab with ben no pad no pain
looking back
really i didn't have no friends i was
looking up the drillings they didn't
have no skins i just booked the hotel
for the little man again
his mom's relapsing she gone rehab again
i could do it for the clout the things
i've done for my friends and family
even the ones i know doubted me but i
feel the energy in the air it will be my
haters that make me legendary when i'm
there
i'm legendary when i'm dead and i will
never see repentance for anything that i
did because i risked it
every day for that chocolate biscuit
misfit i've never been a victim and i
was in jail trying to pattern my
thickness he was in jail [ __ ] i've
seen too many crooks start snitching
next thing they're hanging themselves on
the sticks is i've lifted twisted sick
[ __ ]
how am i supposed to tell my thought
about this world that she lives in my
childhood is torture because i'm
drinking look at him hypocrite sat here
drinking recalled that i felt my [ __ ]
start sinking surrounding myself with
some leeches i wasn't thinking
i got back at it my number memorized by
every crack and smack at it
but i built up my own bad habits causing
stat damage fronting people who are
backstabbing
loyal for one minute then they stop
backtracking that's why i'll never make
a video with no gang and i was kicking
those with those straps once you do it
you can dash mashes
firing you're wrong risking my chat
mansion i called whip switch plate swept
jegs till i decamp it
rob sims then i revamp it he burst a lot
of bubbles when he slammed manners
[ __ ] bricks imagine if he hadn't wet
the hammock cause that's the gear for
every suite let alone the attachments
and see just got his d
cat he'd soon be back in action imagine
the adam westerhammers because that's
the year for every street
[Music]
tv
you